hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer questions
from one of my favorite breeders in the
char who wrote in asking about whether I
have a home office or go to an office to
work so the specific question was I've
tried working from home but haven't been
as successful as it's been at the office
now people at home want me to work from
home as if it's also spend more time
with me what do you suggest for me work
from home or have an office so a couple
points for you it's a great question a
lot of entrepreneurs go through the same
thing and stretch if you're a solo
entrepreneur or you manage a team that's
remotely we don't have to go into an
office because people there so you get
the choice as to whether to go to an
office or not I can share with you my
experience and hopefully that helps you
make your decision as to what to do I
found that I'm more productive when I
have an office that I go to and when I'm
there I do my work and I'm more
productive than if I'm trying to do it
from home I find it's easy to get
distracted when you're at home you can
go to the fridge and get some food and
you can hang out and you might get
sidetracked by a home project that you
need to get done it's just so easy to
get distracted you need to have really
strong discipline and ideally you want
to make it easier to get your work done
and not force yourself to get your work
done so I find going to an office helps
with that regard the second thing is
having boundaries and I find it's again
easy for people to overstep those
boundaries if you are at home so I don't
you have children or not if they're
knocking on your home office door and
then and they want to come in you know
you can say you're working but then
you're going to feel really guilty
afterwards right because you're not
spending time with them and then that's
going to decrease your productivity of
doing that work because you're feeling
so guilty for returning them away or you
let them come in and you know play in
your office and again that's kind of
taken away from your work time so having
those boundaries is important and it's a
lot easier to do it when you have to
have a physical office to go to the last
thing I found is it a lot of
entrepreneurs will blur the lines
between personal
office and you want to make sure that
your personal time is for you that
you're spending time with your family
and proven yourself and your business
time is focused on the business if
you're the kind of entrepreneurs always
always always you know working then
you're going to turn your family away
and not going to have successful
relationships so I find it's important
that you have an office you know you're
going to the work and when you come home
you may be still you know you may get a
couple of ideas for your business write
them down or send them and send an email
to yourself don't let it take over your
day so that you know when you're
supposed to be saying time with your
family you're still thinking about work
and doing work if your home is your
office then it's a lot easier to blur
the lines and always be working compared
to if you have to have an office to go
to you know that that's your time for
work and then your hometown is your time
to be at home in my case right now I
schedule I'm in the office five hours a
day from Monday to Thursday and the rest
of the time I'm at home or dancing or
doing some of my son or whatever
whatever is on the schedule I find that
to do that effectively it's enough time
so if I have 20 hours a week that's
enough time to do everything you need to
do for my business but I need that time
to be able to actually do it so I need
those 20 hours would be highly focused
and really attentive on doing what I
need to do for my business can't afford
to be sidetracked thinking about other
things are getting distracted otherwise
instead of taking 20 hours it takes me
30 hours of 40 hours because I've been
so distracted and interrupted then it's
a lot harder to get your project done so
the pitch to your family might be I want
to spend more time with you guys but to
do that I need to be able to really
focus on my works that when I'm working
I'm working and then when I'm with you
I'm with you so you can probably end up
working fewer hours between way more
productive in those hours and get maybe
even more work than then usually do and
then
more time to go and stand with your
family so hopefully that helps again
that's you know my experience if you
guys like this video please give it a
thumbs up I love seeing those coming
that makes me want to do more videos for
you guys and if you have a question
about a home office life or you want to
share your experience is what you're
doing or a different question for your
business I'd love to hear it for leave a
comment under the video I always read
the comments and try to respond to each
one what I can so thank you and you'll
see you on the next episode
you